martin watts sur un site d'offres
d'emploi un poste d'ingénieur
intéressante dans une grande firme
questionnaire par courriel entrevue
téléphonique
tout le processus d'embauché est
parfaitement crédible on lui annonce
qu'il obtienne poste mais il doit suivre
une formation
il reçoit son contrat avec un chèque de
6000 $ pour payer sa formation ce que
martin ne sais pas si tu le chèque sans
provision même si l'offre d'emploi
semble authentique c'est de la frime
les fraudeurs qui sont derrière savent
qu'il faudra plusieurs jours avant que
la banque s'aperçoivent que chez qu'il
faut et martin lankais ce même jour les
fraudeurs prétendent qu'il y avait eu
erreur réclame le remboursement
martin tombent dans le panneau et leur
envoi 6000 $ lorsque la banque
s'aperçoit que le chèque est faux retire
l'argent de son compte et bart un verre
donc tout cet argent fin mot de
l'histoire
les fraudeurs ont du génie soyez avertis